[Music]
we're gonna give you the awards out real
short late
I just wanted really to say I'm really
I'm really proud of you guys
and seen you all here you show up
hearing and hearing their stories it's
really really awesome and what's
happening within the in this generation
of people I have to work
[Music]
but tonight we've been lucky enough to
win property Entrepreneur of the year so
our prop strategy the moment is ready
service accommodation I want young
property investor of the Year award
which is an amazing award I'm so
thrilled of a certain one that the award
we've won this evening it's presented
with this best property networker of the
year for me this means a lot and it's
about my ability to communicate with
investors I was fortunate enough tonight
to win the deal sorcerer of year for
2019
what the investor believes this means so
much to me because I'm notes like coming
to all the crash courses and helping
everyone out and giving people advice
from how can I say
[Applause]
I just want to say a massive thank you
this is so overwhelming
yeah I said silence don't make me cry
seriously I just want to say thanks for
all your support and it means a lot to
me because property and as this can be
quite lonely right and when how Facebook
group that supports you it's so much
better I don't see anyone that is
sitting here thinking that they're
supposed to be here before you begin
this and I have to say that there's
something else honestly you've been
inspirational and it's always your
friend just like that
thanks for the support I've received out
getting toward and all coaches and bob
has amazing support and thanks to
everybody
to my beautiful chef she wants a player
like that the Karimi is looking bright
back get the huge bastard are back
contrast she's playing with that so I
mentioned I said I check how computer
beep I don't wanna do is get her out of
the car and on the dance floor where the
bass solo her mom moves to the right
[Music]